I'm what they call an elder Millennial
80s baby 90s kids early 2000s teen in
other words I've been subjected to some
of the most toxic body image and diet
messages at a very vulnerable time in my
life it wasn't without a damn good fight
but somehow I survived and I say if we
want to look forward we sometimes have
to look back so let's take a look at
some of the completely idiotic diet
advice that I got from rom-com called
Classics growing up hey everyone I'm
Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
we'll be taking a look at some of the
worst diet tips that I learned from
movies as a kid but first please pause
the screen or look at my description for
a disclaimer including a huge trigger
warning as we will be showing some
potentially very kind of pro-ed style
content here so if this is triggering to
you please skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and guys if
you are new here please help a YouTuber
out hit that subscribe button and follow
me over on Tick Tock and Instagram at
Abby's kitchen before we get too far
into things I want to hop in here to
talk to you about my sponsor cook Unity
so I know cooking is like part of my job
but there are days when five o'clock
rolls around and the kids are whining
and I just can't sometimes I don't have
the inspiration sometimes I don't have
the time sometimes I don't have all the
ingredients and sometimes I just don't
have the drive add in a little winter
holiday with my kids in Florida and I
have even less interest in cooking from
scratch so as soon as I landed I stocked
up on some of the creative signature
meals from cook Unity so cook Unity has
over 50 talented chefs from some of the
best restaurants in the country working
out of regional micro kitchens instead
of massive production facilities so you
feel like you're getting a restaurant
meal at home basically you let them know
what you like and what you don't like
and you pick a flexible meal plan so you
can get as few as four or as many as 16
meals per week then you can select from
hundreds of meals that align with your
preferences and dietary restrictions
including keto vegan gluten-free low
sodium and more and they use really high
quality chef-driven ingredients the
meals are delivered fresh not frozen in
compostable recyclable or reusable
packaging along with expiration dates
heating instructions and nutrition stats
and then a few days before your delivery
you get a text message to make your
selections for the next week feels like
one big thing off my plate that I just
can't screw up I love their meal salads
and their fish and chicken dishes are
all so delicious there are tons of great
options that the kids love too the menu
rotates constantly with a wide range of
different cultural flavors and
preparations so it really helps to fill
the gaps with inspiring fun meals for
those nights when things get super
hectic so if you want to try cook Unity
out for yourself go to cookunity.com
Abby or click the link in the
description and use my code abby50 to
get 50 off of your first order of meals
all right back to the video okay I'm not
gonna lie I know basically all of the
movies that we're about to watch clips
from by heart most of these were or are
still favorite movies of mine so don't
think I'm like ripping them apart as
being so bad I [ __ ] love these movies
too so I can see past the Ridiculousness
of the diet tips because I know that
they are largely satire but it's worth
pointing out that basically all of these
movies that I looked up to Growing Up
feature white thin beautiful women
talking to other white thin beautiful
women about how to lose weight or look
thin not surprisingly most of these
movies have an aged well and sure we
could 100 make this video like an
hour-long dissertation about how pop
media in their early 2000s often played
up the patriarchal cool girl Trope as it
pertains to diet and yes I could go off
on how damaging these messages were to
me and potentially so many other young
women growing up but I'll give you the
Kohl's notes instead yeah it was [ __ ]
up and while the early 2000s were rough
times for women in the media and
therefore also for a lot of young women
consuming it it's potentially even more
damaging now that social media has made
all of these messages even more
pervasive and ultimately seem more real
if you want to learn more about the
history of a lot of these messages check
out my video right here now I just want
to say that in some of these cases we're
going to laugh at the absolute
Ridiculousness of the suggestions and in
others we're potentially going to be
bringing up some very triggering
disordered suggestions so again I want
to remind you to skip this video if
that's not supportive to your journey
alright let's take a look at some of the
blood diet tips that my generation made
me believe First up my favorite Clueless
sure that's fat three oh yes sir I'm
gonna lose weight by doing it like this
okay so Cher Horowitz was low-key my
idol in grade four much to my father's
dismay and at age eight I literally
remember thinking that this hot tip like
must be legit science as if the calories
would just like get mangled up and
vanish when you cut them up real small
to be fair Cher also convinced me that
coffee would stun my growth
that's not true by the way but at the
time I too thought I want to be 510 like
Cindy Crawford FYI and Trigger warning
for what I'm about to say but this
tactic of like cutting up food really
small is often a recommendation in
eating disorder circles likely to make
the experience of eating feel like it
lasts a lot longer Looking Back Now as
an adult it was probably not a great
hack to promote to Young Folks but I
still love this movie tidbits so let's
move on
oh you total Binger
April this is gonna go straight to your
ass wow Bianca you look really good too
um are you eating less or just barfing
more holy [ __ ] like remember what I said
about not aging well the hot chick in
this case is literally code for the cool
girl Trope it's the unnatural and
confusing juxtaposition between eating
whipped cream off of a massive milkshake
too knocking cake out of a girl's hand
suggesting it's going to go straight to
her ass very indicative of the times I
would say basically the concept here is
that to be cool you need to look like
you eat like a lot of fun Carefree foods
but to be hot you need to be thin in
real life this can be a near impossible
scenario for young women which is really
why it's so problematic also the genre
of movies seems to just love literally
making fun of bulimia and other
legitimate Eating Disorders case in
point light beer and she's gonna throw
it up anyway and this one two weeks
until the parenting I was practiced seen
my talent finishing my costume brushing
up on current events and running 18
miles a day on about 400 calories I was
ready yikes okay so full disclosure I
loved pageant movies growing up and to
this day I think drop dead gorgeous is
like one of my all-time favorite movies
if you haven't watched it is true genius
and I've got the whole damn thing
memorized so obviously I get that these
were comedies and the latter
specifically was a classic satire but I
just feel like lines like that wouldn't
fly today because we just kind of know
better the 90s and 2000s didn't do a
great job acknowledging the dangers of
disorder eating and eating disorders
likely because they seem to be a rarity
at the time when we know just how much
more prevalent they actually are but
when we know better we can do better and
making fun of Eating Disorders now kind
of just feels like a really cheap
comedic choice and speaking of eating
disorders and satires trigger warning
ahead this is a very suggestive and
possibly a bit dangerous of a clip for
some folks to watch so just please skip
this again if it's not supportive for
you I am so grateful that you guys are
sharing your not food lunch with me but
won't we like die if we eat cotton balls
only if they call to block it in our
intestinal tracts but that's what the
sauce is for lubrication and it gives
you that wonderfully full feeling
without all the calories again yes it
was a satire and I can appreciate a joke
I'm not dead inside folks even if I am a
former Eden disorder Warrior myself I
also don't love censoring art if I don't
know you want to call these super cheesy
teen horror flicks art but I think the
worst part about this clip is not the
cotton ball meal because that to me
clearly felt like they were insinuating
it was a bad idea to copy I mean the
pretty little cotton boxes also makes it
clear that this isn't real life it's
kind of a joke but the line like eating
cotton balls gives you that wonderfully
full feeling without the calories
feels like a slippery slope to me
obviously eating cotton balls is a
common recommendation on Pro Ed forums
so making that connection between
something seemingly idiotic as eating
non-edible substances and helping you
feel full without calories or gaining
weight can definitely risk serious
buy-in from vulnerable communities but
let's move on to a more recent high
school called classic mean girls so much
Ridiculousness here to enjoy folks and I
will take any excuse to re-watch Lindsay
inner Heyday let's call the South Beach
fat flush and all you drink is cranberry
juice for 72 hours this isn't even
cranberry juice it's cranberry juice
cocktail it's all sugar
I want to lose three pounds I can't go
to Taco Bell I'm on an all-carb diet God
Karen you are so stupid is butter a carb
yes Katie all I've been eating are these
counting bars they suck no no this is
just how they work this is all your
water weight first you bloat and then
you drop 10 pounds like that
well the counting bars have burned up
all your carbs and now your body's just
running on water but once the water's
gone then you'll be all muscle I mean at
least we can all have like a little fun
with this one everything about Mean
Girls is comedy and that's specifically
evident when the diet to allegedly lose
weight is like all carbs it's literally
the opposite of what's been in Vogue for
like the past 20 years so yeah talk
about jokes we are also naturally made
to love the protagonist aka the cool
girl Katie who seemingly is happy to
like eat all the things and we're meant
to despise the villain Regina George who
is always on a diet and what happens to
the people we hate well in this case
they end up fat
you're going fat ass
I mean when you tune into these story
lines I just find it so interesting that
gaining weight seems like the ultimate
punishment for being a person that or I
guess getting hit by a bus and shove it
right up your hair
in any case no butter is not a carb no
don't go on an all-carb diet no don't
drink cranberry juice or any juice
exclusively for three days to try to
lose weight I mean teenagers as these
actresses were pretending to be should
not be tormenting themselves over losing
weight and dieting at all never mind
losing like three pounds to fit into a
dress and even though it's all a big
joke I do think that movies like this
normalize this desire to weigh less and
diet at a young age when we really
should be thinking nothing about
changing our body to fit into a prom
dress and if we need another mirror
mirrored example of this popular teen
flick Trope look no further than Lindsay
Lohan's former teeny bopper Frenemy
Hilary Duff what can I get here that has
no sugar no carbs and is fat free
water water again it's really sad that
these were the kind of examples of how
teenage high school girls should be
eating you know protagonist Underdog
eats real food obnoxious bully
apparently does not classic and speaking
of classic it would not be a Roundup of
the worst dieted face on the Silver
Screen without a nod to this popular
scene and The Devil Wears Prada
well I'm on this new diet It's very
effective well I don't eat anything and
when I feel like I'm about to faint I
eat a cube of cheese
well it's definitely working I know I
just want the stomach flu away from like
going away you don't deserve them you
eat carbs for Christ's sake
okay Loki this is one of my favorite
movies of all time Emily Blunt Anne
Hathaway and Meryl Streep are a legit
dream team of a cast but yeah I don't
think we really need to go over why
starving yourself to the point of
fainting isn't a good idea nor why you
shouldn't be exploiting like a bad flu
or bug to help you lose weight again
obviously this is comedy and it's
brilliant comedy at that but if it were
real life it would be a major Ed red
flag hey is this real life and even if
this were to be a low risk way to lose
weight what happens when you stop the
crash diet or like recover from the flu
Oh I know you gain all the weight back
and oftentimes even more so also this
whole like get sick to get skinny Trope
is nothing new and nothing old I mean
remember this called classic I was so
lucky getting mono that was like the
best diet ever
I mean we may think diet culture has
evolved over the the decades but yeah
not much has changed so let me reiterate
how much I love these movies they shaped
who I was as a young person for better
or worse but they all hold a very
special place in my young girl Nostalgia
card but I think with much more
knowledge and openness and discussion
around eating disorders in the media
screenwriters are becoming a little more
sensitive to how they portray a diet
culture in the movies at least that's my
hope maybe they're worse today and I'm
just kind of out of the loop because I'm
35 and I either watch true crime or coco
melon with my kids but leave me a
comment below with your thoughts and
other crazy dye culture messages that
you learned in movies that you watched
growing up and on that note that's all
that I have for you guys today if you
like this be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below subscribe to
the channel and I will see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]